there have to be more tombs out there in
need of raiding so why didn't 2018s Tomb
Raider ever lead to another adventure
you can thank Amazon for that Tomb
Raider was one of the hottest video game
series of the 1990s centering on Lara
cof A Relic hunting Adventurer the first
film adaptation of the Tomb Raider
franchise was Angelina Jolie's 2001
Adventure flick it earned a healthy $273
million at the box office a solid take
for a turn of the Millennium action
movie and enough to get a sequel quickly
green lit in 2018 the Baton was passed
to Alicia vander's Tomb Raider reboot
and it earned almost the exact same
amount yet there's been no followup
since but the reason why is more
complicated than ticket sales a sequel
was in the works for a 2021 release but
it quickly hit a snag with the outbreak
of Co 19 in early 2020 just as things
were apparently ramping up theander was
repeatedly asked about the sequel and in
a chat met with collider in 2021 she
seemed unsure if it was still going to
happen explaining preo I would have said
yes and now I think it's a yes still
it's not green lit but the script is in
the making and I think everyone is
excited and I would love to revisit Lara
again those delays may have cost them a
sequel because in 2022 Amazon acquired
MGM which forced the franchise into a
complicated legal limbo and the rights
lapsed an anonymous Studio source told
the rap there was a pre-negotiated
ticking clock that had been agreed to
and there was no way to rescue it in
time MGM asked the rights holders for
more time but their patience had run out
even though Tomb Raider was met with
decidedly mixed reviews upon its release
it has achieved a mild cult status with
fans who would love to see theander back
as Laura Croft in a second movie and it
seems the filmmakers and its cast would
love nothing more than to reunite for
another go in 2021 Lovecraft country
Creator Misha green signed up to write
and direct a sequel howdy Tomb Raider
fans my name is Misha green and I'm the
writer director of the upcoming Tomb
Raider movie The cander seemed
particularly pumped about the prospect
of working with her telling
Entertainment Weekly in 2021 I hope we
go and make another movie because of the
pandemic we had plans of shooting this
film and now it's been 1 and 1/2 years
but Misha green is on board and she's
riding a draft right now ever hopeful
theander seemed ready to strap on the
guns and get back to adventuring adding
it would be so amazing if we get to go
and do this very big ass film together
going to kick some ass in front of the
camera and behind the camera a year
later though theer's tone shifted and
she cautioned that the odds were stacked
against them telling movie Zen in 20122
I'm good at going back to that role and
it would mean a lot of training now it's
a lot of talk considering that Amazon
has bought MGM and after the pandemic
there is so much politics so right now I
actually do not really know what is
happening if there's going to be a Tomb
Raider sequel it would of course have to
star Alicia bander as far back as 2019
with a sequel already in early
development there wasn't actually
concrete word on whether Vander would
reprise the role with people reporting
that it was still unclear whether she'd
be back but that question was answered
when the actress officially signed up
and she began speaking about the sequel
publicly sadly most of her comments were
regarding its long delay Beyond viander
there isn't much known about who else
from the cast might have reappeared in
this proposed sequel though an
unverified report in 2020 did suggest
that Christen Scott Thomas would return
and that she'd have a much metor role
the actress had played a smaller part as
Anna Miller Lara's men and a colleague
of her father in the 2018 film Anna is a
bigger bad in the video games and
according to the rumor she would have
been bumped up to the main villain for
the sequel which had been teased at the
close of the first film you can pick
pick up where he left off Tomb Raider
was helmed in 2018 by a relatively
unknown Norwegian filmmaker named roor
utak who a few years later directed The
Cult hit troll the script was penned by
Geneva Robertson dwar in her feature
film debut alongside co-writers Evan Dy
and Alistair siddens Roberts and dwar
went on to work on Captain Marvel but
neither She nor utog were expected to
return for the second Tomb Raider film
after it began development instead
writer Amy jum was signed in 2019 to pin
the second film and Ben Wheatley Inked a
deal to sit in the director's chair but
as the delays on the film began to pile
up the studio made significant changes
to the crew behind the camera which saw
both Amy jump and Ben Wheatley dismissed
from the project replacing them was
Misha green who was announced to both
write and direct the sequel in 2021
though no reason was given as to the
swap in filmmakers nevertheless green
got right to work and by May she was
telling her following on Twitter that
the first draft of the script was
complete but that there was still a long
journey to production long in this
instance was a hell of an understatement
you might as well tie a stone to your
foot and jump off the boat now though it
took more than a year after Tomb Raider
was released before the studio was ready
to commit to a sequel they finally did
put the Wheels in Motion in 2019 in fact
rumor has it that the Tomb Raider sequel
came fairly close to beginning
production and no nember 2019 report
from hn entertainment claimed that
viander was signed on the script was
ready to go and the studio was locking
down locations for shooting per that
same report which was seemingly never
confirmed by any of the major trades MGM
Studios Was preparing to bring the
production back to the UK where much of
the first movie was filmed Warner
Brothers leaves in studios was even said
to be the place where they would set up
shop for the sequel before it all fell
apart what's known for a fact is that
this version of the movie was supposed
to start shooting in early 2020 although
pandemic related shutdowns forced the
project to be put on hold and then its
release date was taken off the calendar
altogether it wouldn't be until 2021
that it got back up and running by then
green was the writer and director of
record and her version of the film was
also further along than some fans May
realize as it happens it even had a
title Tomb Raider obsidian and viander
was expressing excitement over an
imminent production start that never
came nobody but those involved know what
the sequel would have been about when it
was under the stewardship of writer Amy
jump and director Ben weatley however
some word has trickled out over the
years of what might have happened in the
version written by Green cobbled
together from various tidbits that
leaked during its development and after
the film was shuttered in addition to
talk that Kristen Scott Thomas would
return in a bigger role as the main
villain of the film audiences also got a
brief glimpse of some of the action in
late 2020 22 when storyboard artist Jake
Lunt Davies posted a series of images
that he' created for the project on
Twitter what they revealed didn't give
away too much of the plot but they did
showcase a pulse pounding sequence that
may have kicked off the story with a
daring attack on Croft Manor carried out
by shadowy agents given the ending of
the 2018 Tomb Raider and the rumored
larger role for Anna Williams it's
possible this raid was orchestrated by
Laura croft's Mentor sparking a quest
that would take Ur to various locations
to get to the truth if there's anything
still standing in the way of a direct
sequel to 2018 Tomb Raider it isn't the
pandemic problems with the script or
scheduling with the actors instead it's
the fact that a reboot to the franchise
was announced in early 20123 this stems
from mgm's loss of the rights following
their acquisition by Amazon with an
apparent bidding war taking place for
the chance start from scratch
Blockbuster news shaking Hollywood this
morning Amazon buying mg g m Studios for
8.5 billion bucks the winners of that
bidding war were of course Amazon who
quickly announced Grand plans for a
total reboot of the movie with a new
actor taking over for theander the deal
was a big one for the streaming service
which includes much more than just the
rights to make a feature film and while
numbers weren't announced The Hollywood
Reporter suggested it only fell a little
short of their gargantuan deal for the
Lord of the Rings the announcement came
on the heels of the news that Amazon
would be getting into the video game
publishing business and it would be
putting out the next Tomb Raider console
game from developer Crystal Dynamics
details at this time are still sketchy
with no writer announced for the film
let alone a director or a star but that
doesn't mean that Amazon hasn't started
work on the project and they have in
fact made bigger plans that could see an
explosion of Tomb Raider across multiple
media platforms after snagging the
rights to a Tomb Raider adaptation the
folks had Amazon have revealed they'll
be crafting a big screen reboot but that
isn't all the film will be just one part
of a larger tapestry and they have plans
to turn the franchise into a
full-fledged Cinematic Universe to make
that happen they have announced that a
Tomb Raider TV series is in the works as
a streaming original with plans for the
show and film to be tightly integrated
with both each other and the already
announced video game relaunch even more
exciting is that spearheading the effort
behind the scenes will be Fe Waller
Bridge the three-time Amy award-winning
Creator and writer of fleabag star of
Indiana Jones in the dial of Destiny and
co-writer of the 2021 James Bond film no
time to die according to the trade
Waller bridge will write the series but
is unlikely to be involved in the film
and while many fans may have jumped to
the conclusion that she might play Laura
Croft 2 that doesn't appear to be the
case one actor who has stepped up to
volunteer for the title role is Michaela
J Rodriguez who told variety I would
like to tackle a roll like Laura crof I
would love to do that because I have the
badassness and sex appeal to make people
love it if not I would also love to be
Laura croft's right-hand girl who gets
just as much airtime and is right next
to her killing it with a Cinematic
Universe on its way that will reboot the
franchise with an all new cast and crew
it might seem like a sequel to 2018s
Tomb Raider has no chance of ever seeing
the light of day but if one steps back
and takes stock of the Hollywood
landscape
they'll see that a return to that
Universe isn't really far-fetched and it
could actually still happen even if it's
not anytime soon after all recent films
like Spider-Man no way home and the
Flash have seen the return of actors who
audiences thought they'd said goodbye to
decades ago with both Toby Maguire and
Michael Keaton returning as Spider-Man
and Batman versus Angelina Jolie that
would be a cool film and while there's
very very little chance that Amazon
would use a Multiverse gimmick to have
previous Lura crofs meet although that's
what Studios all seem to think the fans
want the idea of returning to the
continuity of a previous movie even
after a reboot isn't without precedent
itself the Terminator and Halloween
franchises both did just that after all
from the sounds of it even star Alicia
Vander would still be up for reprising
the role years down the line theander
told Variety in 20123 for me that was
another one of those childhood dreams to
portray an action character was awesome
and Beyond what I ever thought I would
do and I think the physical part is
something that I really enjoyed so yeah
if another opportunity like that came
again I'll be
[Music]
interested